in this video I'm going to introduce you
to the concept of the convolution
convolution for one of the first times
mathematicians actually named something
similar to what it's actually doing
you're actually convoluting the
functions in this video I'm not going to
dive into the intuition of the
convolution because the convolution
there's a lot of different ways you can
look at it has a lot of different
applications and if you become an
engineer if really of any kind you're
going to see the convolution in in in
kind of a discrete form in a continuous
form and a bunch of different ways but
in this video I just want to make it I
just want to make you comfortable with
the idea of a convolution especially in
the context of of taking Laplace
transforms
so the convolution theorem why don't we
actually before I even go to the
convolution theorem let me define what a
convolution is so let's say that I have
some function f of T let me just so if I
convolute F with G so this is what this
is means that I'm going to take the
convolution of F and G and this is going
to be a function of T and so far nothing
I've written should make any sense to
you because I haven't defined what this
means this is like those SAT problems
where they say like you know a triangle
B means a plus B over 3 if you're you
know while you're standing on one leg or
something like that so I need to define
this in some similar way so let me undo
this silliness that I just wrote there
and the definition of the convolution
we're going to do it over a over well
there's several definitions you'll see
but the definition we're going to use in
this context there's actually one other
definition you'll see in the continuous
case is the integral from 0 to t of F of
F of t minus tau F of t minus tau x
times G of T let me well stain let me
just write Slice times G of tau D tau
now this this might seem like a very
bizarro thing to do when you're like Sal
how do I even how do I even compute one
of these things and to kind of give you
that comfort let's actually compute a
convolution
let's say that and it's actually was
hard to find some functions that are
very easy to analytically compute and
you're going to find that we're going to
go into a lot of trig identities to
actually compute this but if I say that
f of T if I define F of T to be equal to
the sine of T and I define cosine of T
let me do it in orange or I define G of
T to be equal to the cosine of T now
let's do some let's convolute the two
functions so the convolution of F with G
with G and this is going to be a
function of T it equals it equals this
I'm just going to show you how to apply
this integral so it equals the integral
I'll do it in purple the integral from 0
to t of f of t minus tau this is my f of
T so it's going to be sine of t minus
tau times G of tau well this is my G of
T so G of tau is cosine of tau cosine of
tau D tau so that's the integral and now
to evaluate it we're going to have to
break out some trigonometry so let's do
that this almost is just a very good
trigonometry and integration review so
let's evaluate this but I wanted to
evaluate this in this video because I
want to show you that this isn't just
some abstract thing that you can
actually evaluate these functions so the
first thing I want to do I mean I don't
know what the antiderivative of this is
it's tempting you see a sine and a
cosine maybe then the derivatives of
each other but it's a sine of t minus
tau so let me rewrite that sine of t
minus tau and we'll just use the trig
the trig identity that the sine of t
minus tau is just equal to the sine of T
the sine of T times the cosine of tau
minus the sine of tau times the cosine
of T and actually I just made a video
where I go through all of the the the
trig I go through these trig identities
really just to review them
or myself and actually to make a video
in better quality on them as well so if
we make this substitution this you'll
find it on the inside a cover of any
trigonometry or calculus book you get
the convolution of F and G is equal to
MLS write that F star G I'll just write
it with that is equal to the integral
from 0 to t of instead of sine of t
minus tau I'm going to write this thing
right there so I'm going to write the
sine of T times the cosine of tau minus
the sine of tau times the cosine of T
and then all of that times the cosine of
tau all that's times the cosine of tau
have to be careful with my towels and
T's and let's see T and tau and tau and
T yeah everything's working so far so
let's see so then that's DT let me put
that or sorry D tau to be very careful
here now let's let's distribute this
cosine of tau out and what do we get we
get this is equal to so f F convoluted
with G I just go to F star G it's equal
to the integral from 0 to t of sine of T
times cosine of tau times cosine of tau
I'm just distributing this cosine of tau
so it's cosine squared of tau and then
minus let's move right the cosine of T
first and I'm doing that because we're
integrating with respect to tau so I'm
just gonna write my cosine of T first so
cosine of T times sine of tau times sine
of tau times the cosine of tau times the
cosine of tau D tau and now since we're
taking the integral of really you know
two things subtracting from each other
let's just turn this into two separate
integrals so this is equal to this is
equal to the integral from 0 to t of
sine of T times the cosine squared of
tau D tau minus the integral from 0 to t
times cosine of cosine of T times sine
of tau cosine of tau D tau now what can
we do well is simplify it more but we're
integrating we're integrating with
respect to let me be careful here we're
integrating with respect to tau I wrote
a T there we're integrating with respect
to tau so all of these this cosine of T
right here that's a constant the sine of
T is a constant for all I know T could
be equal to five it doesn't matter that
one of the boundaries of our integration
is also a t that T would be a five in
which case these are all just constants
we're integrating only with respect to
the Tau so if cosine of you know if
cosine of five that's a constant we can
take it out take it out of the integral
so this is equal to this is equal to
sine of T times the integral from zero
to T of cosine squared of tau D tau and
then minus minus cosine of T that's just
a constant I'm bringing it out times the
integral from zero to T of sine of tau
sine of tau cosine of tau D tau now this
antiderivative is pretty straight
forward you could do u substitution and
now let me do it here instead of doing
it in our head this is a complicated
problem so we don't want to skip steps
if we set U is equal to sine of tau then
D u D tau is equal to the cosine of tau
right just the derivative of sine or we
could write that D U is equal to cosine
of cosine of tau D tau right and then of
course this is from well well we'll
we'll undo the substitution before we
have evaluate the the endpoints here but
this one's a little bit more of a
conundrum I don't know how to take the
antiderivative of cosine squared of tau
it's not obvious what what that is so to
do this we're going to break out some
some more trigonometric identities and
in the last in a video I just recorded
it might not be the last video in the
playlist I showed
I showed that the cosine cosine squared
of Tao I'm just using Tao as an example
is equal to one half times one one plus
one plus the cosine of two Tao and once
again this is just a trig identity that
you'll find in really in the inside
cover of probably your calculus book so
we can make this substitution here make
this substitution right there and then
let's see what what our integrals what
our integrals become so this first one
over here let me just write it here
it'd be we get sine of T sine of T times
the integral from 0 to T of this thing
here let me I could just take the let me
just take the one-half out so let me
just to keep things simple so it's x so
I'll put the one-half out here that's
this 1/2 so 1 plus cosine of 2 tau and
all of that is d D tau
that's this integral right there and
then we have this integral right here
minus cosine of T cosine of T times the
integral from let me be let me be very
clear this is this is tau is equal to 0
this is tau is equal to 0 to tau is
equal to t2 tau is equal to T and then
this thing right here I did some u
substitution if u is equal to sine of T
then this becomes u and we showed that D
U is equal to cosine u is equal to sine
of tau and then we still showed that D U
is equal to cosine tau D tau so this
thing right here is equal to D u so it's
u D u and let's see if we can do
anything useful now so this integral
right here the antiderivative of
this the antiderivative of this is
pretty straightforward so what are we
going to get let me write this outside
part so we have 1/2 times the sine of T
and now let me take the antiderivative
of this this is going to be tau plus the
antiderivative of this it's going to be
1/2 sine of 2 tau 1/2 sine of 2 tau I
mean we could have done a used
substitution we could have said U is
equal to 2 tau and and all of that but I
think you can do that from recognition
and if you don't believe me you just
have to take the derivative of this sine
of a 1/2 sine of 2 tau is the derivative
of this is U you multiply you take the
derivative of the inside so that's 2 so
the 2 and the 1/2 cancel out and then
the derivative of the outside so cosine
of 2 tau and you're going to evaluate
that from 0 to T and then we have minus
cosine of T and then we're going to have
we take the antiderivative of this let
me do this on the side so the integral
the integral of UD you that's trivially
easy that's one-half u squared right now
that's one-half u squared but what was
you to begin with
it was sine of tau right so the
antiderivative of this thing right here
is 1/2 u squared but u a sine of tau so
it's going to be 1/2 u which is sine of
tau squared and we're going to evaluate
that we're going to evaluate that from 0
to T and we didn't even have to do all
this use substitution the way I often do
it in my head I see the sine of tau
cosine of tau if I have a function and I
have this derivative I can treat that
function just like if I had an X there
so it'd be sine squared of tau over 2
which is exactly what we have there so
it looks like we're in the homestretch
it looks like we're in the homestretch
we're taking the convolution of sine of
T with cosine of T and so we get 1/2
sine of T now if I evaluate this thing
at T
what do I get I get T plus 1/2 sine of
2t that's when I evaluated at t and then
from that I need to subtract it
evaluated at 0 so minus 0 minus 1/2 sine
of 2 times 0 which is just sine of 0
right so this part right here this whole
thing right there what does that
simplify to well this is 0 sine of 0 is
0 so this is all 0 so this first
integral right there simplifies to 1/2
sine of T times T plus 1/2 sine of 2t
plus 1/2 sine of 2t all right now what
does this one simplify to over here well
this one over here you have minus minus
cosine of T and we're going to evaluate
this whole thing at T so you get 1/2
sine squared of t minus 1/2 sine the
sine of 0 squared which is a 0 so that's
just minus 0 so so far everything that
we have written simplifies to let me
multiply it all out so I have 1/2 let me
just pick a good color 1/2 T sine of T
right I'm just multiplying those out
plus 1/4 sine of T sine of 2t and then I
have over here I have minus 1/2 sine
squared T times cosine of T right I just
took the minus cosine T and multiplied
it through here and I got that now this
is a valid answer but I suspect that we
can simplify this more you may be using
some more trigonometric identities and
this this guy right there looks ripe to
simplify and we know that the sine of 2t
sine of 2t
another trig identity you'll find out
the inside cover of any of your books is
equal to the sine is two times the sine
of T times the cosine of T so if you
substitute that there what is our whole
expression equal you get this first term
let me scroll down a little bit you get
one-half T times the sine of T plus 1/4
sine of T times this thing in here so x
times 2 sine of T cosine of T just two
trig identity nothing more than that and
then finally I have this minus 1/2 sine
squared T cosine of T no one ever said
this is going to be easy but hopefully
it's instructive on some level at least
it shows you that you didn't memorize
your trig identities for nothing so what
is this simplest let me rewrite the
whole thing or let me just rewrite this
part so this is equal to 1/4 now I have
well let me see 1/4 times 2 so it's
really 1/4 times 2 is 1/2 and then sine
squared of T right at the sign times the
sine sine squared of t cosine of T and
then this one over here is minus 1/2
sine squared of T cosine of T and
luckily for us or lucky for us these
cancel out and of course we had this guy
out in the front we had this 1/2 T sine
T out in front now this guy cancels with
this guy and all we're left with through
this whole hairy problem and this is
pretty satisfying is 1/2 T sine of T so
we just showed you that the convolution
the convolution if I define let me write
our result
I should normally I feel like printing
this instant you're kind of writing this
in stone because this is so much work
but if we write that f of T is equal to
sine of T and G of T is equal to cosine
of T I just showed you that the
convolution of F with G
which is a function of T which is
defined as the integral from zero to t
of F of t minus tau times G of tau D tau
which was equal to and I'll switch
colors here which was equal to the
integral from zero to T of sine of t
minus tau times G of tau D tau that all
of this mess all of this convolution it
all equals and this is pretty satisfying
it all equals it all equals one-half T
sine of T and the whole reason why I
went through all this mess and kind of
bringing out the neurons that had the
trig identities memorized or having to
reprove them or whatever else is to just
show you that this convolution it is
convoluted and it seems a little bit
bizarre but you really can take the
convolutions of of actual functions and
get an actual answer so the convolution
of sine of T with cosine of T is
one-half T sine of T so hopefully you
have a little of intuition of well not
intuition but you at least have a little
bit of a hands-on understanding of how
the convolution can be calculated